foreign
let's go to Jack in Tampa what's up Jack
hey Dr deloney how are you I'm good man
what's up
well uh if you if my memory serves me
right uh these episodes are recorded
about a month before they're dropped
which means this thing will drop right
about Christmas time
so if you don't mind I'd like to wish
you and all the folks at Ramsey
Solutions and all the listeners across
the
Ramsey land here a very merry Christmas
to you and all your families and hope
the holidays find you well thank you so
much man and you too hope you guys have
a great Christmas
well
uh so the reason I'm calling
is
um
my uh so I'm
going uh through a divorce I've been
going through it for about two years now
since my wife left me
um once you leave and
uh we'll um
you're gonna make me jump to my
secondary problem very quickly here
um usually the secondary problem is
hidden behind a pretend first problem
[Laughter]
well uh
I don't know why my wife left me for
sure
um why has she told you she left you
boy you got cameras somewhere
um
nope just been doing this a long time
and you have a very evasive Cadence
why did she leave her she told you very
directly and you don't like what she
said or you don't want to believe it why
did she tell you she left you
actually it's because I I can't remember
why
um so
uh I have a problem with blocking out
I guess uncomfortable things so I've
asked her twice
and the first time I don't remember
anything about what she said
and the second time I asked her I tried
really hard to concentrate on what she
was telling me
and
um my brain took me to a
different place I completely tuned her
out
um like I just like she was talking
through a pillow like she was talking
but I wasn't able to focus on anything
she was saying
and uh
when did this start
I'm not sure
um I didn't realize it was really a
problem
until that happened and then
I've been staying with my little sister
through this divorce process and we were
talking about some things that happened
in our childhood when we were teenagers
and she's was telling me about something
that happened to her and I was there and
she says oh but you probably don't
remember because you're like Mom you
forget things
that are uncomfortable which
I have no idea what she means about my
mom I got hung up on the whole me thing
so that's the first that was the first
time you'd ever heard that
yeah from somebody else and so you have
she disclosed that
like you were there when abuse happened
or family trauma happened but you just
block it out like always and because
nothing happened
and that was the first you'd ever heard
of that
yeah yes and no it was the first
we had some things happen in our what
early early childhood
so let me let me uh absent um a brain
tumor
or absent
um some significant uh brain lesions or
absence some horrific childhood trauma
you're gonna have to get real Direct
because there's a vagueness to how how
you how you just interact does that make
sense
yeah and it's a protective measure and I
understand it and it makes complete
sense
but it becomes self-reinforcing and so
the healing here is directly through the
middle of it so like what are the things
that happen as when you were a kid that
you that you can remember that you know
about
oh God
nobody wants to hear a grown man cry on
Christmas
um
Hey listen here's the deal I love you
and I don't
I can hear it on you
but I want how old are you
32. okay I want you to be very honest
with yourself about how this sort of
evasiveness
on the truth and the stories that you
were born into and that happened to you
what that is what that has given you
it's giving you a lot of Heartache
and so here's what I'm offering you an
opportunity to try to practice something
different
which is let's be very direct
what happened
uh if you don't Hey listen if you don't
want to that's okay I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna bully you into it I'm not
gonna brow beat you
but I I do want you to know healing will
be going right through the middle of
this and you'll probably need a very
skilled trauma counselor and I would
recommend if you were my friend I'd
recommend that you go get a CT scan to
make sure you don't have some sort of
uh
challenges with the with your with your
physical brain but memory and Trauma and
anxiety all that stuff is wound together
in a pretty remarkable way
okay it's all that stuff is really
tightly abraded together and so if you
got problems with memory and you got
problems with family trauma
that's a brain trying to take care of
you
okay yeah that that that's um
that's why I wasn't going to really
address it because I thought maybe it
wasn't that big of a deal if I just
don't remember bad things so incorrect
that's all because your heart remembers
and your brain remembers and your body
remembers
the frontal lobe part the part that just
lets you go on about your day and check
the who won the game and making sure you
get the TPS reports turned in
um that can just go about its day
but your body keeps the score as
Vandercook says and it is revving and
revving and revving and if you've looked
at the aces score the adverse childhood
experiences score it's a scale of one to
ten I want you to Google it after this
it's called Aces there's a million of um
sites you can go to but it's just a 10
question test
foreign
the higher your Aces score
five six I think four is when it starts
really changing but six seven and eight
things that happen to you in your
childhood become predictive of strokes
and heart attacks and Cancers and
dementia and other things
because your body is at War
okay and so it feels like just
pretending none of this happened
is the way forward and by the way
replaying it all is not part of
everybody's healing Journey either it's
not like you're gonna have to sit down
and just like hit rewind on all the
videotapes and start again
but you're gonna have to make peace with
what happened
and you're going to have to begin
practicing being present with hard
conversations in the now
yeah right
yeah that that was going to be my next
question is can you even really fix yes
I mean well you're not you're not broken
your brain is working perfectly
so I don't want you to think you're
broken
your brain experience some stuff
right
yeah some evil craziness
and so it has learned
the best way is that we unplug
and we will plug back in when the threat
has passed
and so you're not broken there's nothing
to fix can you be healed yes I believe
with all my heart you can
there's too many incredible advancements
right now in
all kind of trauma therapies and
different trauma therapy techniques and
some of the map stuff with some of the
psychedelics with people who knows
there's too many too much stuff out
there
um ketamine therapists too many
therapies out there that are working
just doing miraculous things when done
with a trained provider
so yes I have every bit of confidence
uh
when uh
when me and my uh sisters were
very little
um
I was like
I want to say it was between the ages of
three and six I want to say I was in
kindergarten when my parents finally
took us away
God I can't uh okay hey don't let's just
stop right there okay
here's what's important about what you
just did
you provided a GPS pin you know where
right
yeah you know where
and um your brain throws a curtain up
and it'll allow you to dig back to that
curtain I'm gonna recommend you don't go
through that curtain by yourself right
now okay
okay
but I am going to recommend because I
love you gonna care about you I want you
to call somebody
as a Christmas gift to yourself man
you've been doing this for 30 years
it's exhausting right
yeah
did you love your wife
a lot yeah it hurts
and my guess is she loved you too and
she just went as far as she could go
right
I I don't know I don't know that's what
I'm guessing all right
yeah okay
are you ready to be well and healed
yeah yeah I think so what's the
hesitation man
you ever think something about yourself
but
you'd call yourself all the time but
it's wrong
once you can
you can't stop thinking that way about
yourself so were you sexually abused as
a kid
oh God
I I uh just just yes yes or no though
let me say it this way the words you are
using are very
uh common among people who were sexually
abused as young children
foreign
okay
not saying you were I'm not putting that
into your head if that's not the case
that's not the case but the words you're
using tell me that you as a young child
suffered terribly
okay I um yeah I mean I I don't I only
know what I was told okay so all right
let's don't go into there on this call
okay let's keep this let's keep this um
where it needs to be until you've got a
professional in the room with you okay
okay are you suicidal in any way no no I
I'm not uh suicidal I just okay do you
work do you have a job
no I have quite a bit of work um yeah I
work um what do you do dude
uh
uh well
I work uh full time as a truck driver
and then I'm I work a secondary job
part-time on the weekends as uh working
in a warehouse
and uh students you're not scared of
hard work right
no no I I've scared of sleep apparently
um
just uh just working um and doing a
school at night just
trying to get my finances in line and um
uh my divorce is pretty well
buttoned up just got the
um hearing coming down the line and uh
to have a judge sign off on everything
and there's a custody agreement I'll
have 50 50 custody with my
a little girl uh but contingent on I
have to move to within 50 miles of my
wife and she lives in a bit of a
uh expensive area so I gotta okay
um I'm just trying to get everything in
line to be able to do that be there for
my
that's my daughter which is which is the
uh the point of this call is I just
don't want to screw up my kid with the
um
the the junk that's uh that's my life so
just have you
um are you abusive
uh no not that I'm aware of nope that's
not the question I asked you is the
answer yes or no are you abusive
uh no I'm not abusive put a period at
the end of that sentence
one of the Hallmarks of childhood abuse
is that everything has a dot dot dot at
the end of it because you're never quite
sure where it's coming from because the
people that were supposed to keep you
safe the adults in your life are the
ones that hurt you
and so everything is a uh I think I I
don't no you don't abuse your daughter
right
right stand on that
for the first time since she was born
stand on that
you're not afraid of hard work are you
earning a good paycheck
a couple of good people yes you are
you're a good dad
okay stand on that do you have some
skills to learn absolutely you do we all
do
yeah do you have a lot of healing to do
absolutely
but you're doing you're stepping in the
right direction okay I wish you wish it
hadn't taken a divorce to get your
attention here we are okay here we are
yeah the only thing you can do from this
point forward is decide what happens
next
you can't go back and edit what happened
when you were a kid
can't go back and edit the kind of
husband you were or we're not
you can just aside from this point
forward what am I going to do
yeah right
all right and so you're gonna have to
practice
putting a period at the end of your
sentences
okay that's hard
because those got you hurt man
I can't tell you enough you have you
cannot do this by yourself you're gonna
have to call a trauma counselor in your
area Okay do you promise you'll do that
what is what what will happen
if they're a good trauma therapist they
will sit down with you and they will
walk you through how your body responds
in the present to things that happened
in the past
and it will be you will learn some
skills on how to regulate your body when
it starts to leave a conversation you
will learn skills to stay present in
that conversation even if it's a
conversation that says if you don't fix
a b and c I'm going to divorce you
or I am filing for divorce from you and
you say what happened and then all of a
sudden your body's like Hey we're not
sitting around for this because the last
time we sat around for this when you
were seven or you were three
the other stuff happened so we're out
and you will learn skills to stay
present
and a good trauma therapist will not
drag you through every memory of the
past to make you dredge up the past or
some pretty damning research about
that that could be re-traumatized that's
not the point the point is
how can I take ownership of my body in
the present
that's the goal and some of that does
have some revisiting that happens but
not in the Gory graphics and all that
okay
okay
but what we're looking for here is
peace
and you have never had that
let me describe no let me describe it
can you imagine it being nine o'clock
and you laughing and deciding huh
I could either go to bed
and crash or I can just watch a movie
and you just deciding that not because
you have to because you get to and then
you wake up in the morning and you
decide I think I want to have coffee not
because I have to have chemicals to prop
me up but just cuz
yeah can you imagine dating somebody and
telling a joke and they don't laugh very
hard
and you don't instantly go into a shame
spiral because you're the stupidest
person ever and you're an idiot you just
go like that was a dumb joke you know
what I mean
or your boss comes in and says your
butt's gonna go do this and you say
I I'm actually I'm not have a great day
I've taken care of my finances I'm good
to go I'm going to be at a place where
I'm respected
or it's that guy cuts you off in your
car and you don't go to insta rage
blackout rage you just let him over you
just nod and be like all right dude in a
square Kia go about your day
peace
you tip that waitress at Waffle House a
hundred bucks on Christmas Day because
you can
because she doesn't want to be working
there on Christmas day but she has to
and you get to on like that's peace man
peace and you've never had that because
your body's been trying to defend you
since you were three
from the people that should have taken
the best care of you
yeah okay that's what I'm talking about
and then your daughter is gonna feel
that connectivity and there's not going
to be a react like a nuclear reactor
she's going to be in the presence of a
dad who's safe
not who says all the right things no Dad
does and not who doesn't say dumb things
and mess up all dads do but a dad whose
presence is
that guy somebody I can anchor into
yeah right
right does that sound good
that sounds
that sounds uh it's a fairy tale right
yeah it's a fairy tale yeah okay so
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give
you
um a copy of my book own your past
change your future I want you to read it
and I'll also send you
um a digital copy so you can listen to
it if you're not a reader you can let's
do it while you're driving okay
and the whole book is about making peace
with
these things happen to me whatever these
things happen to be
and then that terrifying question what
do I do next
and the second thing is in exchange for
sending you the book and both versions
of that book you my friend are going to
fulfill your promise and call a trauma
counselor today
you're gonna call somebody today and
you're gonna make an appointment today
so by the time Christmas rolls around
you've had one two maybe three sessions
with them let them know I'm scared I
don't trust you I don't trust adults I
don't trust any of this
and they'll say great have a seat
would you like some tea
and now my brothers were healing's gonna
start
and at some point you'll say sorry to
your wife when the lights come on
and at some point she may see you and
say oh my gosh
there he is
your daughter's going to want to be
around more and more and more and more
because
peace and make no mistake my man this is
gonna be a hard hard journey
and make no mistake my friend
you're worth every step of the way thank
you for calling and trusting me man
I'm grateful for you